head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard charts Tucker
was asking about the the people and the
companies behind the creation of these
computer systems in Ai and I said
actually James has some deep insights
into what these companies do yeah this
this um well you said it today Charlie
about the 10 commandments within IBM on
pbd show I connected all the stories
together CU they're two seemingly
unrelated stories so IBM announces all
this AI growth and their stock goes up
and then James O'Keefe reveals that they
have the Ten Commandments that govern
the values of IBM and so basically IBM
is telling you that they're creating a
woke super weapon this is so demonic no
no that's basic and exactly and the Ten
Commandments are not you know the 10
that were revealed to
Moses they're literally like that white
people can't be racist that black people
can be do nothing wrong that Ali sh it's
literally it says quote understand only
white people are racist it is the is
that an exact quote that's an exact
quote the anti-racist decalogue is what
and you said something pretty profound
you said that eventually AI will make
this the actual ten command well that's
what I'm saying yeah I mean if if you
think for a I mean there're you youal
Harari has already said that artificial
intelligence is going to rewrite its own
religion for Bible stories that quote
make more sense for people wow yeah I
mean there're of course they need to go
after the actual Ten Commandments it's
not going to be honor your mother father
it's going to be honor your lesbian
black Master yeah yel Harari also said
that the era of Free Will is over um
that's the type of centralized thinking
that these individuals are
all Tucker Tucker you you you said that
they were creating a God they're
creating a demon they're creating a
devil well a false god if Anil yeah for
sure no it's a it's a demon but they're
but what's so interesting is at least
you know in the the whole management
carfuffle over there at AQ um the letter
that got him bounced briefly from the
helm said these people are are like you
know dancing around the proverbial fire
worshiping this thing and I'm like of
course they are course rituals attacked
yeah they have the golden calf in just
just to go off but it's important the
their stated goal he y Val herrar uses
Bible stories all the time that's what's
so creepy he talks about like the flood
he talks about the Tower of Babel they
since Nimrod tried to create the city of
Babel in Genesis 11 they've been trying
to reconstitute a Oneness of the
government and a Oneness of the world
they think artificial intelligence will
allow the let it's a one world
government that they have always been
after what they're going to do it
through that's why God scattered the
people Babel means god confuses Babel
God confuses because God does not want a
One World Government he wants Nations he
and now you add that to the fact that a
lot of people think especially
politicians like Netanyahu that believe
that we're in the end of times and when
you see his conversations that he has
with Elon Musk especially when it comes
to artificial intelligence a lot of
things start to come together when it
comes to the time that we are in right
now that is going to be absolutely
decisive for Humanity we could either be
totally free or totally enslaved and
that decision might not be ours I I want
to talk about one of the first
iterations of artificial intelligence a
lot of people say this is not true AI
fine we don't got a nitpick on it but
Sheamus brought it up these these these
AI girlfriends that have been popping up
all these different apps where they
whisper sweet nothings into the ears of
young men to confuse them to pull them
away from from reality the scary thing
about it is people the these young men
they're they're on their phones and they
think they're just having a chat on
their phone you're not behind this AI is
a singular machine a singular entity
whether you want to believe it's it's
it's some kind of conscious being demon
whatever it is a single entity and each
of its fake girlfriends that is talking
to these young men is like a tentacle
coming out of it so these young men they
think they're they're being wooed by a
siren towards the great seas to die and
it is a gigantic demonic Beast them to
them but I just it's so lonely I mean I
believe in smell very strongly if if I
can't smell you you are not real and so
I I mean that I you know and I don't
understand how people could fall for
that like in the end it's some computer
generated image it's utterly fake like
how it's like sadder than a sex doll let
me get needlessly uh a scientific for
just for Ian because he's not on the
stage anymore there's this really cool
thing called a laser induced plasma
Channel now the one day this military
guy is like hey I would really love to
strike a guy with lightning with a gun
how do I do that well the problem is
lightning travels in the path of least
resistance so they got an idea they use
an infrared laser I'm probably getting
this way wrong but follow bear with me
anyway you you use an infrared laser to
charge the air in a straight L straight
line ionizing the particles which
creates an easier path for electricity
they could then point a cannon and fire
a bolt of lightning essentially it's a
waste of energy so it didn't really work
out but the reason I bring this up is
for fun but mainly because young men are
having a hard time meeting girls I mean
especially with the me too stuff and all
not America Fest but yeah not an America
Fest America Fest is great and that's
why people should come to things like
this to meet people but imagine you know
all of those challenges of Teen Angst
and it is not easy to to live I mean
this is just reality you have to you
have to strive you have to struggle you
have to fail and pick yourself back up
but Along Comes the Candyman who says
ignore all of that and I can satisfy all
your deepest emotions with this machine
right here and so unfortunately a lot of
young men they might think to themselves
you know I will try and meet actual
girls and get a real girlfriend but you
know I'll just use the app for now then
eventually they develop antisocial
behaviors they never meet people they
never developed those skills by the then
they're 20 years old and they have no
idea how to even talk to someone but
more importantly the great opportunities
to meet someone when you're young in
your neighborhood used to be Church your
families and communities would meet uh
Public Schools I'm not a big fan of but
also a way that people would meet and
the workplace now we're working from
home now young people are are using
these apps and and they're not even
communicating anymore if we get to the I
mean we when we're talking about these
AI girlfriends as this just I just view
this as a tremendous evil understand
that dead internet Theory whether anyone
wants to believe it's true or not is
coming true factually before our eyes
because we're looking at AI Bots
communicating with us of course
eventually now Twitter is integrating
grock at at what point does grock start
actually posting things and
communicating with people and at what
point does someone create a bot using a
paid script from GPT or something to
make Twitter accounts or accounts to
communicate with people and then you're
there you're you're you're you're in the
fake world and we may already be
there does anyone still think it's
important to go outside and be with
animals yes yeah this is why we moved to
West Virginia yeah CU now I have a
family of deer that live on my lawn it's
so important turkeys you learn more from
them than you will from grock trust me
chickens we got a lot of chickens and
chickens are Bas AF so we're we're very
great but you were describing Tim what
better way to depopulate a population
than to do exactly that what you're
describing and uh you know take Andrew
Tate out of his business so James walk
us through because this is some of the
greatest work and I just have to say
this James O'Keefe and Tucker Carlson
have both had challenging
223s and I think I speak for all of us
we're so blessed and thankful that
they're back and fighting stronger than
ever right Tim it's amazing to have you
guys on stage together if you think
appreciate it if if you think about it
the regime did what ever they did I
think I I have strong thoughts on that
but they're both stronger than ever
because they're both threats James we
love you and we support you tell us
about this is one of the most important
stories you have published in quite some
time thank you Charlie um and thank you
Tim and nice to see you again Tucker
great to see you jam um I I I think that
this story is remarkable because usually
there's a couple people that maybe come
to me now there's been 150 people with
an IBM that have come forward
150 and U I'm going to break something
right on your your show here well I'll
post it on X so I guess I'll break it on
X and also on your show and this slide
says how does whiteness work this is an
IBM internal document I I talked to you
a little about it Tucker but it's the
red hat which is the subsidiary of IBM
and it says quote whiteness constructs
the game hides the rules then rigs the
game over and over again it's this it's
this slide that they give out inside IBM
and so there's really kind of an
explosion of whistleblowers coming
forward it's very encouraging and I
think that uh that could have a real
effect in 2024 I think the Whistleblower
is going to be very important in 2024
people on the inside with access to
what's happening yeah I'm fairly
optimistic I got to be honest I mean
with what you're saying especially but
we just have to we have to be vigilant
well it's almost like the first person
you know you has to take an extreme leap
of faith and then everyone else will
follow but this is a sort of
whistleblowing in in numbers in in big
numbers I've I've never seen that before
and it's very encouraging to me but
someone has to come forward first and
that person is still within IBM IBM deep
throat is still there so I'm very
encouraged by that Charlie because
usually it was a couple people but it's
hundreds and I think that that's going
to be a a taste of what's to come and
the CEO has responded right CEO was on
an all staff meeting a foreigner who
became an American arid Krishna because
he said if you if you hire you know
white people or there's too many Asians
will dock your bonus and terminate you
so then he gets on an all staff Call
last week and he says there there's this
video that came out okay of me and I
said these things and he's talking to
tens of thousands of people and he says
don't give this any Oxygen don't get
this any response and that was recorded
and leaked and published yeah so the CEO
is telling everyone inside the company
don't respond to this so I don't know
what they're what they're going to do
now they can't fire a 100 people this is
built in culture and the message James
you've spread for a long time of be
brave has reached a lot of people and if
everyone holds that within their hearts
that they will always be brave in s for
they believe in we need not worry about
this in 10 years but that's that's
hoping and in numbers I think people
need to do it in numbers we if anyone's
watching to connect all this together we
need more whistleblowers than these AI
companies right now we need
whistleblowers right now in these AI
companies to come forward with what's
really going on how advanced is is this
technology that we don't know enough we
have like we had one didn't you Tucker
didn't you have a Google whistleblower
that said it already reached Singularity
yeah and um yeah it just it's been Happ
happening like so many Trends in our
society in slow motion and you sort of
see it and you register alarm and then
like deep ominous dread and then you
sort of move on to the next unfolding
crisis and it doesn't feel like anyone
can pause long enough to address any of
them and they're just sort of moving
inexorably forward almost autonomously
and if you put it all together you're
like what are we watching here we're
watching like an actual pivot point in
history and I don't think I'm being
alarm I'm not an alarmist by temperament
I have a sunny disposition I think and
um but I don't have have I don't see you
can reach any other conclusion from that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net